>>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
NEARLY 40 YEARS THE WORLD'S
LARGEST ACTIVE VOLCANO MAUNA LOA
IS ERUPTING ON HAWAII'S BIG
ISLAND.
RIGHT NOW LAVA IS FLOWING DOWN
THE MOUNTAIN BUT WE'RE TOLD IT'S
NOT PUTTING ANYONE IN DANGER AT
THIS POINT BUT AN ASH FALL
ADVISORY IS IN EFFECT AND
SHELTERS ARE OPEN.
LET'S BRING IN METEOROLOGIST TOM
SEDER.
THIS VOLCANO IS SO LARGE IT
COVERS AFTER THE ISLAND BUT LAVA
ISN'T THE CONCERN, IT'S THE AIR.
HELP US UNDERSTAND.
>> RIGHT.
BACK IN 2010 A VOLCANO IN
ICELAND ERUPTED, ANA, I'M SURE
YOU WILL REMEMBER THIS, IT'S
KNOWN FOR SHUTTING DOWN THE
WORLD, THE VOLCANIC ASH AND THE
ERUPTION SHUTS DOWN AIR SPACE
YOU CAN'T FLY IN IT.
FOR A COUPLE WEEKS IN EUROPE
THERE WERE NO FLIGHTS.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT PROBLEM YET
UNLESS WE HAVE ANOTHER ERUPTION.
HERE IS HONOLULU WELL TO THE
NORTHWEST, HERE IS THE BIG
ISLAND, SHADED IN GRAY, THAT IS
THE ASH FALL ADVISORY, IT'S BEEN
EXTENDED UNTIL 10:00 A.M.
BECAUSE OF THE ASH.
IT CAN BE TOXIC, WHEN IT RAINS
IT CAN BE ACID TICK, IT WILL
DAMAGE THE CROPS, LIVESTOCK
UNFORTUNATELY WILL BE HARMED
WITH THIS.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY SEE THE PAST
LAVA SCARS HERE IN THE CENTER,
BUT THIS IS THE OUTLINE OF MAUNA
LOA.
SO, YES, THE LARGEST VOLCANO ON
OUR PLANET WOKE UP THIS MORNING
AND WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS.
NOW, SCIENTISTS, LOCAL
SCIENTISTS, VOLUNTARILY CANNISTS
HAVE BEEN WATCHING THIS SINCE
UNION AND MONITORING THE
ACTIVITY.
THIS IS WHEN YOU GET TO THE
PEAK.
I WANT TO OUTLINE FOR YOU THIS
IS THE LAVA THAT HAS BEEN
BUILDING UPWARDS.
SO THE PRESSURE IS BUILDING.
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT OBVIOUSLY
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO RELEASE
THAT PRESSURE, CAN BE FROM AN
ERUPTION OR SOMETIMES WE HAVE
THESE FISSURES AROUND THE SIDES,
IT'S LIKE STEAM VENTS AND
SOMETIMES THEY CAN ERUPT, YOU
WILL SEE A COLLAPSE ON THE
VOLCANO.
BETWEEN 1843 AND 1950 ON AVERAGE
MAUNA LOA WOULD ERUPT EVERY
THREE AND A HALF YEARS LIKE
CLOCKWORK.
FROM 1850 TO TODAY IT'S FIVE
YEARS AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
IT JUST WENT THROUGH THE
QUIETEST PERIOD IN HISTORY OF 38
YEARS.
NOW, WHEN WE LOOK AT THE IMAGES
OF THIS, THIS IS THE CALDERA
INFRARED IMAGE, THEY'VE BEEN
MONITORING THIS, TOOK A FLIGHT
OVER THIS MORNING.
LOOK WHERE HILO IS.
THAT'S A CONCERN BECAUSE WHEN
THE VOLCANIC ASH SLIDES OVER A
COMMUNITY IT CAN BE TOXIC.
AUTHORITIES ARE SAYING WEAR A
MASK.
THE LAND AROUND VOLCANO IS THE
MOST FERTILE IN THE WORLD THAT'S
WHY FARMERS WORK THIS.
THAT'S A CONCERN FOR FARMERS AND
LIVESTOCK.
WE ARE SEEING SOMALIA HAVE A
FLOWS BUT IT'S CONFINED TO THE
PEAK.
WE ARE KILAUEA 2018, IMAGES OF
LAVA SCORCHING HOMES AND MAKING
ITS WAY TO THE OCEAN WARTS.
THIS IS VIDEO OF THAT SCENE FROM
THIS MORNING.
YES, WE STILL HAVE PRESSURE
BUILDING, ANA, THERE COULD BE
ANOTHER ERUPTION BUT RIGHT NOW
THE ADVISORY ONLY UNTIL 10:00
LOCALLY BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T SEEN
A MASSIVE ERUPTION.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ACTIVITY
THIS IS ALL EARTHQUAKES AND
THEY'VE BEEN WATCHING AND IT'S
BEEN PICKING UP IN INTENSITY,
YOU WILL SEE IT GET YELLOW WITH
THE ERUPTION EARLIER THIS
MORNING.
AGAIN, LARGEST VOLCANO, WAKING
UP, AT LEAST SLOWLY.
>> AND THOSE IMAGES ARE REALLY
SOMETHING.
I FEEL THAT WAY, ESPECIALLY
AFTER THANKSGIVING, I'M STILL
TRYING TO MAKE MYSELF FROM MY
FOOD COMA.
TOM SATER, THANK YOU SO MUCH.